investment television Evan Carmichael is  driven by success he is the president  and CEO of Max the intern a successful  software development company in downtown  Toronto for Evan in his band of smartly  dressed Merry Men driving higher revenue  growth is key but not the only reason  why he's in business how much does money  drive me it's a it's there of course the  bigger vision behind Maxie in turn is to  be able to a build an organization where  everybody involved can feel proud of  where we come to work and we can earn  money but also have fun be able to learn  something and reach our potential and be  able to give back to the community  around this